l'agence de prévention des catastrophes
signale que l'objet inconnu est toujours
en mouvement je suis le capitaine
tamoura de la sssp pour des raisons
mystérieuses les kaijou n'apparaissent
qu'au Japon il n a plus qu'une montagne
entre lui et le dép quelle est la raison
principale de votre venue aujourd'hui
objet en approche signalé en dehors de
l'atmosphère qu'est-ce qui se passe
rapport sur la situation l'objet s
craché à proximité non il a l'objet est
en
mouvement alors c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Ultraman bienvenue dans le groupe jeunes
indépendants du gouvernement et quand
vous avez dit po ça veut dire partenaire
être pote c'est se faire confiance j'ai
STI une autre forme d'intelligence que
celle des maintenant tout le monde conna
ton
identité pour moi au nom de cette
belle planète es-tu un extraterrestre ou
bien un être
[Musique]
humain